prime minister boris johnson and eu
commission president ursula von de line
failed to break the deadlock the two
leaders spoke for the second time in
three days and have agreed to meet face
to face in
the coming days to resolve their
outstanding issues
within the last few minutes they
released this joint statement
as agreed on saturday we took stock
today of the ongoing negotiations we
agreed that the conditions for
finalizing an agreement
are not there due to the remaining
significance differences on three
critical issues
level playing field governance and
fisheries
we asked our chief negotiators and their
teams to prepare
an overview of the remaining differences
to be discussed in a physical meeting
in brussels in the coming days well in a
moment i'll be joined by europe
correspondents adam parsons in brussels
but first our political editor beth
rigby
joins me now from downing street and
beth no significant movement this
evening
well kamal this was the call to follow
up the call on saturday when the prime
minister
and ursula von delayan outlined what the
significance
differences between the two sides
remained the sticking points of
we know them well now phishing
governance and of course
competition rules how we have a level
playing field between the uk
and the eu so the uk gets access to the
eu markets but
it doesn't undercut the eu once
we've left the transition period at the
end of the year
the sticking points still remain in a
joint statement
tonight both sides said that they are
taking stock they're asking their chief
negotiators
to prepare a paper discussing
where these sticking points are and yes
the prime minister will go
to brussels at some point we don't know
when
uh to discuss this face to face now with
ursula
von der lion and i have to say it
doesn't really come as a surprise this
call was not
i didn't expect to be the make or break
moment it's not going to be decided
necessarily
in a phone call between the prime
minister and the european union
sorry the european commission president
but rather he would want a face
time meeting in terms of where the talks
are then it's going right down to the
wire
when is he going to go and eu sources
just said to me
the meeting will be probably on the
margins of the european council meeting
that's
thursday and friday this week when the
eu 27 leaders including of course
emanuel macron and angela merkel the
french and german leaders respectively
go
to brussels meet at the council i'm told
it's been decided
as we speak uh and my eu source says the
deal needs to be defined prior
to that and sanctioned at the meeting so
the view from
the european union is that the deal
needs to be sorted out
at that meeting as i said from downing
street no
details at all yet on when the prime
minister will go to brussels but
it's not the end of the road in talks
but it is certainly going down to the
wire
okay beth thank you will it speak to our
europe correspondents um adam parsons
and adam how would you describe the mood
in brussels this evening
well it was pretty gloomy uh for the
whole day to be blunt because
there was no sign of the significant
movement
in negotiations that was required to
create a breakthrough
when michelle barnier briefed eu
ambassadors this morning one said to me
it was depressing monster
it was bleak so there were those who
thought that this phone call
could end up with everyone throwing
their cards in the air and saying right
that's it
i suppose to an extent that these talks
remain alive there may be some
positivity
but the indications i'm getting already
are from some diplomats who are
effectively shrugging and saying well
unless there's movement then this is
just means that
the death has been prolonged uh just by
a few days now of course
we don't know when this meeting will be
a lot of us i think assume straight away
that this
uh meeting would happen in the margins
of the european council on thursday and
friday
so in the past few moments eric malmo is
the the spokesperson
for the european commission uh has put
out a tweet saying let me specify the
meeting
mentioned for the coming days is between
the leaders uh ursula von de line and
boris johnson in brussels i think
effectively saying this is one for the
commission
not for the council but there may be a
serendipity around the fact
that boris johnson could fly into
brussels at the same time
frankly all the decision makers are
going to be in town and that is not just
ursula von de line
that is also well charles michelle the
president of the council but i think
more pertinently
emmanuel macron and angela merkel those
are the people
that he really has to get on site and
it's going to be
hard because for the past few months
there has been precious
little movement on those three key areas
the level playing field governance and
fishery
and there isn't much sign bluntly that
they aren't near
an accord it's gonna have to take rapid
compromise there is and i just got a
message here from uh from a diplomat
this idea that you look each other in
the eye and you blink he said
it just doesn't happen at something like
this what they need
is a negotiated compromise on the trade
deal and at the moment
even allowing for this can being kicked
down the road a bit further that still
feels a long way away